what is it about necessarily the kind of
Instagram which mentioned them and their
15 second limit and vine that's made
vine really it seems from my perspective
online more of a talking point you think
six seconds made it was it was just the
right number i need a video about this
every time a company creates a feature
to compete with something else it's a
feature short form video is vines DNA
bless you shortboard video is vines DNA
it's what they are Instagram added it to
compete with vine always a bad formula
right just like just like poke was gonna
from facebook was gonna do something the
snapchat right just like hashtags on
facebook how's that going right so so i
think that and then i watched all this
is why I don't allow my employees to
read other articles around social media
like there's a really negative point of
view inside vaynermedia to read a de
jour TechCrunch or Mashable because I'm
scared I'm scared because as soon as
that Instagram thing came out everybody
started putting out like articles like
vines dead because everybody's silly
they think scale matters more than it
does they think just cuz instagram has
200 million people that all of a sudden
40 million don't matter and vine it's
not how it works it's never been that
and so everybody sees scale and they're
like well that's dead and that's not the
case DNA matters the the scene in which
a product is born from matters